[Music]
Prince Harry has given his evidence in
court as part of his hacking case
against the daily mirrors publisher
here's everything you need to know
[Music]
Prince Harry is claiming reporters for
the Daily Mirror Sunday Mirror and
Sunday people used phone hacking and
private investigators to illegally gain
information for stories between 1996 and
2010. he claims about 140 articles
contained information gathered using
unlawful methods and 33 of these have
been selected to be considered at the
trial mirror group newspapers denies the
allegations and is also arguing that the
legal action has been brought too late
Prince Harry has spent two days at the
high court giving evidence as part of
this civil case
during his first day in court Harry
criticized Piers Morgan and said in his
witness statement he felt physically
sick at the thought of the former mirror
editor and his band of journalists
allegedly earwigging on his mother
Princess Diana's messages this is what
Piers Morgan had to say he said your
behavior was vile and unjustified what
do you think
I didn't see it
but I wish him luck with his privacy
campaign look forward to reading in his
next book Prince Harry told the court
that stories detailing his private life
would distress
here Sky News has used an actor to
recreate the moment Harry was asked
whose phone he thought had been hacked
to gather information about two articles
one about his mother visiting him at
school and the other about his broken
thumb
the doctors I'm not sure I can't be sure
Mr Green are we not in the Realms of
speculation asked the mirror's lawyer no
I don't believe so again I'm not the one
who wrote the article you'd have to ask
the one who wrote the article
[Music]
prank voicemail left by his brother
William A Visit to a strip club and his
breakup with Chelsea Davey
the prince said Chelsea now has her own
family and this process is as
distressing for her as it is for me the
Duke of Sussex also claimed he found a
tracking device on his ex-girlfriend
Chelsea Davies car in South Africa he
said he would feel some injustice if his
phone hacking claims are dismissed I
believe there is phone hacking at an
industrial scale across at least three
of the papers of the time and that is
beyond doubt
and to have a decision against me and
any other people who come behind me with
their claims given that mirror group
newspapers have admitted hacking and
they have given out I believe over a
billion in settlements yes I would feel
some injustice if it wasn't accepted
[Music]
Prince Harry's time in the witness stand
is up but the civil case is continuing
as more witnesses are called up the
judge will then decide if Harry and the
other claimants in this trial have been
hacked as they claim and no decisions
anytime soon Mr Justice fan court it's
expected to deliver his judgment later
in the year